doch zusammen herzlich willkommen zu zdf
heute live in ihrem live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
in israel toben die heftigsten
auseinandersetzungen zwischen israelis
und palästinensern ja seit jahren muss
man sagen aus dem gazastreifen fliegen
raketen richtung israel richtung
jerusalem das israelische militär
antwortet mit luft steigen auf den
gazastreifen
zwei frauen sind heute durch die raketen
der hamas gestorben 300 raketen wie die
in richtung israel abgefeuert haben auf
palästinensischer seite kamen auch
zahlreiche menschen ums leben 26
menschen gibt die hammers an als
todesopfer darunter auch kinder
das israelische militär wird diese
angaben weder bestätigen noch
dementieren
israels ministerpräsident netanjahu hat
heute abend angekündigt die angriffe auf
den gaza-streifen jetzt noch zu
verstärken und die hamas sagte er werde
in einer art und weise getroffen die sie
nicht erwartet wir wollen heute abend
versuchen das auseinanderzunehmen
miteinander was da eigentlich passiert
ist wie die lage dort gerade aussieht
und wie vielleicht eine lösung aussehen
könnte wenn es sie dann überhaupt gibt
zusammen mit unserem israel
korrespondenten michael bewerunge in tel
aviv mit shimon stein dem ehemaligen
israelischen botschafter in deutschland
und alena ja marine die ist derzeit in
ost jerusalem unterwegs eine freie
journalistin und kollegin von uns die
uns vor ort berichten kann wie die lage
aussieht
eure fragen kommentare wie immer sehr
gerne in die dafür vorgesehenen
kommentarspalten oder per e mail falls
sie oder ihr in der web zuguckt hier zdf
heute.de zdf.de ich gucke dann was ich
hier in den livestream mit rein nehmen
kann
bevor wir jetzt aber tiefer eintauchen
in diese ganze materie und versuchen das
den ganzen wissen auseinander zu
drosseln hat unser kollege michael
bewerunge uns die aktuellsten bilder
zusammengestellt
die raketen aus gaza fliegen zum teil im
sekundentakt und nicht selten gebündelt
auf ein ziel längst nicht alle werden
deshalb vom abwehrsystem iron dome
abgefangen besonders hart wurde die
kleine stadt aschkelon im süden
getroffen wenn die sirenen heulen
versuchen die menschen schutz zu suchen
doch viele wurden heute überrascht zwei
menschen starben dutzende wurden
verletzt
ich hörte die explosion am morgen ein
lautes buh ich konnte nicht glauben dass
unser haus getroffen war
gott sei dank ist den kindern nichts
passiert mit weit stärkerer
militärischer macht schlägt die
israelische luftwaffe zurück sie zählt
nach eigenen angaben auf militärische
ziele unter mast führer doch unter den
über 20 toten und dutzenden verletzten
sind auch viele kinder
ich saß mit meinem kind zu hause
das fing an zu zittern und fiel aus
meinen händen alle meine fenster sind
zerborsten es gab keine vorwarnung
nichts
israels armeeführung sagt ihre
operationen dauerten mindestens einige
tage auch ein krieg am boden sei nicht
mehr ausgeschlossen
trotz des ungleichen kampfes lehnt die
hamas jede vermittlung ab
auch sie könnten noch militärisch
eskalieren drohen die islamisten und in
tel aviv ist es zugeschaltet mein
kollege michael beverungen michael wie
ist denn die aktuelle lage hat sich seit
den letzten minuten was neues ergeben
ja der schlusssatz war leider
prophetisch die hamas droht weiter zu
eskalieren sie hatte ein neues ultimatum
aufgestellt und zwar droht sie das wenn
israel seine angriffe gegen gaza nicht
einstellt dass sie um 21 uhr ortszeit
also einer halben stunde auch mit dem
beschuss von tel aviv beginnen wird dass
sie das dazu in der lage ist steht außer
frage denn sie hat ja gestern auch
jerusalem erreicht die distanz gaza
jerusalem ist ungefähr so wie gaza tel
aviv einen solchen beschluss hat das
eigentlich bisher noch nicht gegeben
es gab einen raketenanschlag vor sieben
jahren sowohl der nähe von jerusalem als
auch in jaffa quasi mehr als vorort von
tel aviv aber dass die hamas heute abend
dazu in der lage ist diese drohung wahr
zu machen das steht glaube ich außer
frage dass du gerade gesagt hat die
hamas wird weiter eskalieren siehst du
da die verantwortung gerade jetzt für
diesen aktuellen konflikt vor allem auf
seiten der palästinensischen
organisation oder wie würdest du das
bewerten wer hat quasi da angefangen den
anführungszeichen und ich glaube man
kann nicht sagen wer in diesem konflikt
angefangen hatte und ich glaube es gibt
auch keine einfachen schuldzuweisung
aber ein symbol mittelbaren konflikt mit
der sehr deutlichen militärischen
eskalation mit den raketen das ist
eindeutig von der hamas aus gegangen
auch wenn man der israelischen regierung
sicherlich ein fehler ansicht und vielen
anderen punkten vorwurf machen kann
aber diese militärische eskalation ist
ganz klar sind terror angriffe gegen
zivilisten israel antwortet auch mit
großer härte und wir haben es ja gerade
gehört netanya auch hat eben auch
angekündigt die intensität der angriffe
auch noch zu steigern wurde gerade vor
wenigen minuten ein großes hochhaus in
gaza angegriffen mit vorwarnungen damit
eventuell zivilisten
das haus verlassen können aber dieses
haus ist in die luft geflogen und
offenbar war das auch der grund für die
abermals zu sagen okay jetzt mit
ultimatum greifen wir auch treffen kann
jetzt gab es ja heute widersprüchliche
meldungen über tote zivilisten tote
kinder weißt du da entsprechend jetzt
mittlerweile schon mehr oder ist das
immer noch vor allem hörensagen und
gerüchte ich habe natürlich keine
genauen angaben weil ich nicht vor ort
gewesen bin aber unsere kontaktleute
unsere producer in jerusalem die der
kontakte auch zur palästinensischen
autonomiebehörde haben sagen dass diese
angaben
wesentlichen verlässlich sind und wir
haben ja auch die opfer gesehen also
dass auch kinder dabei sind steht glaube
ich außer frage unter den toten
ich glaube nicht dass israel bewusst
zivilisten angreift so wie das die hamas
behauptet aber es liegt halt in hn
gazastreifen alles sehr eng zusammen und
natürlich nimmt die israelische
luftwaffe dann kaufte das eben auch
zivilisten dabei getroffen werden die
entstehung dieses konfliktes die ist ja
nicht neu jetzt wenn wir aus diese ganz
aktuelle auseinandersetzung angucken ist
auch diese entstehungsgeschichte relativ
kompliziert die vieles dort in der
region die an frederick fisher hat mal
für uns sortiert was in den letzten
tagen eigentlich passiert ist
seit tagen kommt israel nicht zur ruhe
auslöser sind drohne zwangsräumungen und
zwar im ostjerusalemer viertel sheikh
attar mehrere palästinensische familien
fürchten hier um ihre häuser
weil nach israelischem recht jüdische
ansprüche aus der zeit vor der
staatsgründung 1948 bestehen die
palästinenser sind frustriert sie sehen
aus jerusalem als mögliche hauptstadt
und sich zunehmend verdrängt wir gehen
nirgendwo hin
die leute in sheikh jarrah kommen aus
der arbeiterklasse sie können sich nicht
einfach etwas woanders leisten sollten
sie zwangsgeräumt werden warum sollten
wir auch daran denken das ist unser
zuhause wir werden es nie verlassen
das oberste gericht sollte am montag
über den fall entscheiden
doch der termin wurde verschoben schon
vorher gab es proteste und zusammenstöße
auch gestern am jerusalem tag an dem die
israelis traditionell an die eroberung
ostjerusalems erinnern am ende flogen
raketen aus gaza israel antwortete mit
luftangriffen
ein wichtiger akteur die
terrororganisation hamas
sie hat die rakete nach einem ultimatum
losgeschickt zu dem wir sie eine lücke
füllen
in den palästinenser gebieten wurden
geplante wahlen abgesagt die hamas
bietet frustrierten palästinensern
derzeit eine radikale alternative also
durchaus sehr viele mögliche
konfliktherde michael bewerunge in tel
aviv hier gibt es eine frage auf youtube
mich würde mal interessieren ob die
palästinenser recht haben wenn sie
vermuten dass sich netanjahu also der
derzeitige israelische ministerpräsident
nur als starker mann profilieren will um
innenpolitisch zu punkten was würdest du
dazu sagen ich glaube nicht dass er
überhaupt die macht hatte diesen
konflikt so anzuzetteln
allerdings profitiert hat tatsächlich in
gewisser weise davon denn es bildet sich
gerade so etwas wie eine anti netanjahu
koalition dies aber besteht aus sehr
vielen teilen unter anderem übrigens
auch den arabischen israelis die eigene
knesset vertreter haben und eine anti
netanjahu koalition wurde von diesen
stimmen abhängen bei dem graben der sich
moment auch zwischen israelis und
arabischen israelis die ja letztendlich
auch palästinenser tut ist es sehr sehr
schwierig und sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
dass es da tatsächlich noch zu dieser
regierungsbildung kommt jetzt haben wir
hier in den kommentaren brennenden thema
ist es unausweichlich sehr auseinander
driftende meinungen die einen sehen die
schuld ausschließlich bei israel die
anderen sehen sie ausschließlich bei der
hamas dann gibt es auch diejenigen die
unsere berichterstattung an greifen und
sagen wir werden parteiisch wir bemühen
uns hier wirklich diese beiden seiten
auseinanderzuhalten und neutralen
ausgewogen zu berichten mit ist in
diesem konflikt wirklich nicht einfach
ich habe hier da haben wir gerade schon
gesehen noch mal diese frage mit den
räumen in ostjerusalem das ist ja eine
geschichte die ist so können wir sagen
relativ lokal eigentlich nur aber doch
sehr symbol geladen weil dort vier
familien ihre häuser verlassen müssen
kannst du das noch mal ganz kurz
erklären was da eigentlich dahinter
steckt wie ist so etwas möglich
ja ich glaube das ist nicht nur so im
wohn geladen das ist die spitze des
eisberges alle palästinenser erfahren
jahren in der gesamten westbank und gaza
sowieso eine einschränkung eine
eingrenzung ihres lebens die
siedlungspolitik nimmt ihnen ganz weg
sie müssen demütigung erfahren sie haben
nicht die gleichen rechte wie israelis
und das alles kristallisiert sich quasi
in dieser palästinischen siedlung sheikh
jarrah in ost jerusalem wo palästinenser
seit vielen vielen jahren leben dieses
gebiet hat eben gewechselt 48er
unabhängigkeitskrieg ist es zu den
arabern gekommen im sechs tage krieg
zurück zu den israelis die annexion von
jerusalem ist ja nie international
anerkannt worden trotzdem gibt es
gesetze die sagen das war früher mal das
ist tatsächlich so gehörte tatsächlich
jüdischen bürgern und deswegen ist die
rückübertragung rechtens da könnte man
natürlich auch die rechnung aufmachen
was ist denn mit den grundstücken von
palästinensern in westjerusalem also die
eu hat die klare position dass diese
zwangsräumungen nicht rechtmäßig sind
und natürlich kristallisiert sich an
diesem punkt auch der zorn der
palästinenser für die vielen
erniedrigungen einschränkungen die sie
insgesamt im ganzen land erfahren jetzt
sogar schon die eu-position angesprochen
die da eindeutig ist aber nicht so
eindeutig ist eine einmischung der
internationalen weltgemeinschaft hier
gibt es mehrere fragen in die richtung
also zwei nämlich mal raus warum mischen
sich andere nationen nicht miteinander
das ganze zu stoppen
christian binder ist ein bisschen
eindeutiger in seiner position er meint
erst eskaliert in israel die situation
und dann ermordet israels armee mit
seinen bombardierungen kinder wann
greift die weltgemeinschaft ein und
sanktioniert also wie gesagt es gibt
immer zwei seiten der medaille aber klar
die klare frage ist warum lässt die
weltgemeinschaft das einfach so
eskalieren und schreitet nicht ein
ich glaube da gibt es keine antwort
darauf aber es gibt eben auch kein
einfaches angreifen was ich schon sehen
würde es gibt einen sehr starken
internationalen akteur der könnte
eingreifen
das sind die usa weil die usa besonders
in israel hohes vertrauen genießen als
auch bei den palästinensern und man hat
so ein bisschen gefühl das gefühl dass
israel moment aus dem blick der
amerikanischen administration geraten
ist dass sie selber damit beschäftigt
ist sich aus zu stellen dass auch das
problem nuklearer aufrüstung iran im
vordergrund steht und ich glaube es wäre
zwingend notwendig dass sich momentan
die amerikaner stärker einmischen und
stärker druck zur beilegung dieses
konflikts ausüben ich schaue mal kurz in
die kommentare also es ist wirklich es
ist wirklich sehr gespalten das war zu
erwarten bei dem thema ich habe aber
eine frage an dich noch michael hier
musst du jetzt in tel aviv um dein leben
fürchten also wie bereitet sich die
stadt jetzt darauf vor das ist ja in wie
du sagst in wenigen minuten in
vielleicht noch nicht mal 20 minuten zu
einem bombenangriff oder dem
raketenangriff von der hamas kommen
könnte
also ich hoffe nicht dass ich um mein
leben fürchten muss allerdings nehmen
wir hier alle die gefahr sehr ernst man
ist diese stadt die das ganze land quasi
auf mögliche konflikte ausgerichtet es
gibt überall private und öffentliche
bunker auch wir hier im studio haben so
einen sogenannten schalterraum einer art
bunker die öffentlichen bunker hier in
der stadt sind geöffnet ich glaube dass
die menschen hier schon mit diesen
konflikten umzugehen gewöhnt sind
allerdings wie gesagt einen konkreten
beschuss von tel aviv hat es in der form
zumindest seit den frühen kriegstagen
nicht mehr gegeben und man bereitet sich
mit aller möglichen routine eben möglich
vielen schutzmaßnahmen darauf vor aber
wirklich vorbereiten glaube ich kann man
sich dann letztendlich nicht das habe
ich hier einen ganz schönen kommentar
wie ich finde auf facebook von klaus
seidlitz der meint wäre es wichtiger der
anfänger des krieges oder der anfänger
des friedens aufhören ist das neue
anfangen
jetzt schauen wir natürlich auch als
medien immer auf die
gegen die eskalieren die den konflikt
immer weitertreiben gibt es denn in
israel und im gazastreifen auch menschen
die versuchen zu vermitteln und diesen
konflikt wieder runter zu tunen damit
man vielleicht doch irgendwann
zueinander findet absolut gibt es sehr
viele in israel und auch in palästina
die werden leider nicht gehört man muss
dazu sagen dass dieser konflikt auch in
den letzten zwei jahrzehnten würde ich
jetzt mal nur zurückgehen so viele
wunden geschlagen hat so viele
verletzungen dass das vertrauen massiv
eingebrochen ist gerade auch israel hat
einen ruck nach rechts gemacht die
etablierung der hamas im gaza streifen
zeigt dass auch dort eine
radikalisierung stattgefunden hat und es
ist sehr sehr schwer diese gräben zu
überwinden
ich glaube es gibt viele viele menschen
es gibt auch gerade in israel
diese diskussion vermisse ich manchmal
in palästina einer freien presse
die knallharte alle möglichen optionen
diskutiert welche implikationen daraus
folgen welche fehler israel macht aber
de facto bestimmt natürlich die
regierung und die hat bisher eben einen
sehr harten kurs vor allem auch in den
schrank jahren gegen die palästinenser
bestimmt und hat im prinzip keine
weiteren anstrengungen unternommen um zu
einer echten friedensregelung zu kommen
michael vielen dank für diese
einschätzungen und einblicke aktuelle
lage in israel wir hoffen dass das heute
abend vielleicht doch nicht zu einer
nächsten eskalation kommt aber die
hoffnung müssen wir sagen ist relativ
klein
ich danke dir gerne rainer der mit
diesem konflikt ja aufgewachsen ist seit
seinen frühesten kindes jahren und die
noch lange politisch und diplomatisch
begleitet hat ist shimon stein der war
von 2001 bis 2007 botschafter israels in
deutschland und ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet guten abend herr stein
sie haben ja ein vorgespräch gesagt ihn
kommt diese vage bekannt wurde diese
bilder kommt ihnen bekannt vor was
meinten sie damit angesprochen aber ich
habe meine erfahrung hinter mir und das
alles kommt mir wie sie eben sagten
zitierende
das ist die letzte große
auseinandersetzung zwischen israel und
der hamas fand 20 14 statt und seitdem
befinden wir in eine art mode auf
reaktion manchmal in diesen sieben
jahren ja besser ein oder zwei tage wo
wir und wir uns ausgetauscht haben und
dann ging esche vorbei und nachbar
monaten hatten wir noch eine runde die
etwas länger dauerte die auch etwas
heftig war aber die auch ging zu ende
und nachbar jahren gegen 20 14 hatten
wir eine große offensive die ja mehrere
tage dauerte und wo sind wir heute mehr
oder weniger zurück in eine runde die
jetzt aussieht ja nicht nur ein paar
stunden wurde ein tag oder drei sondern
etwas länger da und wird ob das
anschließend zu einer bodenoffensive ja
mehrere tage da und hörte das ist
momentan nicht abzusehen wie sie ja
wissen manchmal 77
während einer auseinandersetzung gibt es
eine gewisse dynamik die nicht vorher so
war es die nicht geplant ist aber die
seiten rutschen lang zu haben um dann am
ende befindet man sich wo man nicht
unbedingt sein möchte ich glaube dass
die schwelle momentan ja auch wenn die
auf anrufe heute von bevölkerung von der
bevölkerung der neben ja sagt nun
endlich muss das zu ende einmal sein als
sie einmal
aber es hört sich gut an aber trotzdem
meine ich dass das nicht im interesse
der gegenwärtige übergangsregierung eben
auch ist aber wie das am ende aussehen
wird
dazu sagen es gab hier mal doch eine
ganz andere zeit da sah es
zwischenzeitlich so aus als ob das eine
zwei staaten lösung geben könnte als ob
es eine gemeinsame hauptstadt jerusalem
geben könnte
es gab friedensgespräche und dann ist
das ganze wieder zusammengebrochen das
ist schon ein paar jahrzehnte her aber
wieso ist es denn damals dann doch
wieder entglitten
wissen sie dass die frage ob wir so nah
an eine zwei-staaten-lösung bewahren
stimmt ja nicht so sehr
es war das gefühl am ende setzte 2000
das wir anscheinend dabei waren uns
anzunähern
mit hinblick auf eine lösung da war dann
platzte das wie es eigentlich plötzlich
dem der auffassung und teile die
prämisse der theorie der reise und ich
bin der auffassung dass weder wir
bedauerlicherweise noch die
palästinenser reicht die eine beilegung
des konfliktes sind wir auch auf
kompromisse unausweichliche stoßen
müsste und sind wir zum beispiel das
thema jerusalem nehmen so scheint es mir
momentan dass jeder von den beiden
seiten der anspruch auf dort alle die
eben hat jetzt nimmt die oberen für sich
in anspruch die israelis und
palästinenser und die an die ansicht
dass jerusalem so ist meine meinung am
ende so sehr es für uns juden von großer
symbolischer bedeutung ist am ende wird
es auch geteilt werden müssen
wir müssen auch die palästinensische
nationale anspruch endlich hier aussehen
und der die israelische gesellschaft
bewegt sich nur langsam in diese
richtung der zeichen gibt es in der
letzten zeit den meinungsumfragen
zufolge aber die erhoffte reise auf
beiden seiten leider gibt es noch nicht
und ich hoffe dass das wird irgendwann
erreicht werden aber aber was was man
also wenn sie sagen eine bemerkung keine
bemerkt dazu ihre frage an ihren
korrespondenten gibt ja immer eine art
der deus ex machina hoffnung nämlich
weit die parteien nicht in der lage sind
soll soll der druck von außen einen
friedens auferlegen das ist auch eine
illusion die ich ja nicht teile
weil solange die parteien kein interesse
daran haben die internationale
gemeinschaft kann am ende und wird am
ende flankieren und helfen wenn wir
soweit sind aber wenn hier ja nicht so
weit sind kann auch an der intervention
von außen so sehr dass mancher für
wünschenswert halten auch nicht so viel
auch helfen
aber wenn sie sagen die die jeweiligen
jahr starten oder oder bevölkerung sind
noch nicht so weit dann klingt es ja so
als ob es nur extremisten in beiden
lagern geben würde wenn man sich anguckt
wie das aufgeteilt ist dann stellt man
doch fest es gibt eine große zivile
bevölkerung die teilweise auch gemäßigt
ist die zwischen den seiten steht und
dann gibt es die extremisten auf beiden
seiten die ja vor allem den konflikt
weiter anführen warum ist es so
schwierig jetzt zum beispiel aus der
israelischen perspektive die siedler und
die sehr konservativen orthodoxen quasi
so in den griff zu kriegen dass diesen
konflikt nicht weiter eskalieren es gibt
doch sicher viele menschen in israel die
kein interesse haben dass das so
weitergeht wie es seit jahrzehnten läuft
ja es gibt solche auf unserer seite und
hoffentlich gibt es auch solche auf der
palästinensischen seite
aber in ihre beschreibung erscheint
etwas zu idealistisch zu sein denn meine
begriffe ich bin ein linker
mensch ich beobachte seit geraumer zeit
eine freundliche tendenz und der
dänischen gesellschaft die ja und das
zeigen auch die ergebnisse der wahl
einen rechtsruck den städtischen
gesellschaften hier auch zum teil
resigniert das ehrlich gesagt ich habe
das jahr 2000 pro der premierminister
damals barak und arafat mit der hilfe
von klingt so schien als ob wir in
greifbarer nähe verschrien waren und
alles da alles ist geplatzt worden da
kam auch eine geförderte zwischen sehr
viele israelis haben ihre hoffnung
aufgegeben dass es irgendwann zu einer
friedlichen lösung lösung kommen wird
und dazu gibt es auch in dem
zusammenhang ein gefühl das ich
wahrnehme und nicht nur ich dass die
israelis anhalts selbstverleugnung auch
leben siehe wissen dass spielerische
thema beiseite und dann sehen sie dass
in den letzten drei fall dass
palästinensische die palästinensische
frage ein friedensprozess überhaupt kein
thema ein zentrales thema für die
israelis und so glaube ich kommt dazu
die entwicklung der letzten jahren die
palästinensische sache der israelisch
palästinensische konflikt auch von der
internationalen bühne ja nicht mehr im
vordergrund eben ist und für die
israelis
sie haben wir im letzten jahr eine
bestätigung dazu bekommen und das ist
die so genannte abraham akkus denn es
war ja immer so dass man davon ausgingen
dass das ballistische thema das alle
beherrschende thema ist und solange
israel und die palästinenser sich nicht
einigen wird fern die arabische staaten
ihre beziehungen zu israel zu
normalisieren
und nun
sieht es so aus dass es auch arabische
staaten heute juli die arabische die abu
dhabi die emirate bachrain sodann
marokko trotz der tatsache dass der
konflikt noch immer öfter bereit sind
schritte zu nehmen um die beziehungen
mit israel zu normalisieren dann das
wäre ja aber auch was brauchen wir
überhaupt wenn wir anerkannt in der
region werden dann glaube ich möchte
hier weiter so als ob der status quo der
ja dynamisch in unserem interesse ist
und ich teile diese auffassung überhaupt
nicht also das könnte aber auch dazu
führen dass wenn das einer
normalisierung gibt es zwischen dem
israelischen staat und den arabischen
staaten dass das wieder die position der
palästinenser
bisschen besser macht weil man sieht
dass man sich annähern kann
es geht aber auch hier jetzt fragen sie
haben gerade gesagt eine einmischung von
außen wird wahrscheinlich nichts bringen
die ganz klar sagen zum beispiel von
selber auf facebook wo bleiben die
sanktionen an israel wenn es um die
türkei iran russland geht dann gibt es
große klappe nichts dahinter
aber hier vermisst sie anscheinend genau
solche sanktionen und meint das würde
was bringen sind sie der meinung dass
sanktionen gegen israel in dieser
konfliktlage das richtige instrument
wehren wissen sie die frage der
sanktionen ist ja weltweit umstritten
sind eigentlich genug selber wo
sanktionen aufgehängt waren und der
politisch haben sie ja eher die meinung
der gestärkte trotzdem bleiben wir
weiter bei unserer position bleibt ab zu
sehen zum beispiel wie erfolgreich die
sanktionen zb gegen russland sind wie
erfolgreich sind die sanktionen gegen
china und so oft und so weiter so dass
die frage ob sanktionen befinden kennen
können und die parteien in die richtige
richtung bringen damit das gefühl
herrschte die internationale
gemeinschaft kommt das nicht so
wohlwollen entgegen
ein stark register lautet diese diese
muss auch ein preis für ihr verhalten
bezahlen
ich meine sind welche die diese
auffassung sind aber am ende würden
sanktionen nicht das problem
es gibt es ja auch natürlich die die
stimmen die sagen also freiheit gibt es
im frühjahr geschrieben gibt es nur
unter die hamas die hamas ist natürlich
auch einen konflikt treiber in diesem
konflikt eine frage die ich ganz gut
finde von kevin linda die man sich
wahrscheinlich stellt wenn man sich
nicht viel mit diesem konflikt
beschäftigt hat ist was brauchen denn
die beiden länder die beiden parteien
unzufrieden zu sein und keinen krieg
mehr zu führen
die parteien brauchen eine begegnung mit
der realität mit der tatsache dass wir
unbedingt und teilen müssen alles andere
ist vorläufig nur ein rezept für ein
weiteres blutbad und die realität der
kompromissbereitschaft über alle fragen
ist noch nicht vollständig sowohl bei
dem palästinenser als auch bei den
israelis nicht angekommen
dazu kommt dass die israelis
traumatisiert sind und zwar als volk und
die bedrohung auf dem arabischen welt
ist ihnen auch bekannte seit 48 wo sie
eigentlich die grundsätzliche
legitimität eines jüdischen staates egal
in welchen grenzen auch in frage stellen
so dass es herrscht ein gefühl in israel
diese grundsätzliche bereitschaft der
arabischen staaten mit dieser realität
auseinanderzusetzen sie haben kanada
will die hamas
zurzeit kommt das nur überhaupt nicht in
frage
irgendwelchen ausgleich auf friedlichem
weg mit israel zu gelangen
und deshalb glaube ich
bin ich sehr traurig darüber dass die
israelische regierung die ja eigentlich
dem abas der präsident der
brasilianischen behörde unterstützen
sollte derjenige der auch prinzipiell
gegen gewalt angeht er das nicht weil
eigentlich nicht so sehr ihm und uns
geholfen hat irgendwelche schritte die
auf dem weg sein werden ein starkes auch
zur eine friedliche lösung zu gelangen
sehen sie das denn also es gibt ja jetzt
kommentare kommentatorinnen die die
sagen also das ganze wird dargestellt
wie ein konflikt von zwei
gleichberechtigten seiten dabei ist es
ein konflikt david gegen goliath sehen
sie das dann dass es tatsächlich nur so
funktionieren kann wenn beide seiten
bereit sind oder müsste die stärkere
seite die ja doch auch die militärische
vormacht hatte dem gebiet er die
schritte zu machen in richtung in
richtung hamas in richtung gazastreifen
oder sage sie die traumatisierung ist so
stark dass ist in der israelischen
gesellschaft nicht vermittelbar
nein müssen sie jeden konflikt hat zwei
seiten jederzeit reduzierte seite hat
sein narrativ und so entstehen stehen
weil es den ende sehr aktiv über die
ursachen entstehung wohl folge des punkt
genauso wie auf unserer seite aber weil
sie ja eigentlich hamas permanent
ansprechen und nicht die
palästinenserbehörde und nicht die fahrt
nach bewegung und nicht im büro sondern
hamas hamas glaube ich ist die
absehbarer zeit auch herr stein für
stein ich musste kurz unterbrechen mein
kollege michael bewerunge ist noch in
der leitung geblieben und kann uns
aktuell berichten wie die lage in tel
aviv aussieht wir schalten mal kurz
rüber so michael wir hören es im
hintergrund es scheint zu einmal
angekommen zu sein
ja nicht nur zunahme seit 10 vor neuen
ortszeit geht hier auch eine rakete in
richtung tel aviv ab es ist quasi die
hamas hat die drohung schon vorher war
gemacht die sirenen ging los und dann
setzte auch der beschuss ein assist von
über 100 raketen die auf tel aviv
abgefeuert worden sind die rede
einige sollen sogar wissen eh tanja das
ist weiter morden hinter tel aviv
geflogen sein
wir können schlecht unterscheiden es
gibt viele detonationen wenn sie die
vielen raketen die abfangraketen des
albums systems die in den himmel
schießen und dort explodieren
ich habe zumindest selbst hier vom
unserem dach des stückes aus eine
schwere explosion sehen können etwa auf
der höhe von rhi schon wo eine große
rauchsäule in den himmel steigt also es
sind mit sicherheit ist auch eine rakete
durch gekommen wie kann ich mir diese
raketen endlich vorstellen sind es ist
marke eigenbau oder sind das tatsächlich
raketen die man irgendwo erwerben kann
die gibt es nicht im baumarkt das ist
schon marke eigenbau aber schon mit viel
erfahrung zusammengestellt und die hamas
hat in den letzten jahren große
fortschritte gemacht
jetzt hat es hier gerade direkt in der
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft geknallt
aber im moment ist der alarm auch wieder
weg das sind raketen die bis zu einer
reichweite von 120 kilometern inzwischen
haben wollen das heißt sie können viele
viele punkte in israel erreichen
und die sind offenbar gestern zum
einsatz gekommen und komme
möglicherweise auch heute abend zum
einsatz
so hoffen wir dass es in tel aviv der
einzige alarm war die luft schutz die
sie reden sind ausgegangen wenn du
kannst michael bleibt für uns auf
standby aber mach es bitte so dass du
sicher bleibt denn sicherheit geht
natürlich immer vor danke für den
kleinen zwischenbericht und wir schalten
shimon stein der uns weiterhin
zugeschaltet ist wir wollten ja auch
eigentlich noch mit unserer kollegin
elena in ost-jerusalem sprechen aber da
haben wir auch gehört in jerusalem ist
die lage gerade so angespannt dass sie
nicht mit uns reden kann wir hoffen dass
es in den nächsten minuten sich wieder
etwas beruhigt und wir noch mit ihr
reden können aber es kann auch einfach
sein dass das nicht mehr funktioniert
weil wir sehen es wirklich gerade die
lage ist in der region sehr angespannt
und tatsächlich sehr sehr unsicher auch
für korrespondenten und
korrespondentinnen herrscht ein danke
dass einleitung geblieben sind ich habe
hier eine frage von mag noch an sie wo
sehen sie denn fehler auf seiten der
regierung sie haben auch gerade
angesprochen es gibt ja nicht nur die
hamas im gaza-streifen da kann man mal
drüber reden aber hier ist es mir die
frage wo sehen sie die fehler auf seiten
der israelischen regierung
grundsätzlich gibt es kurzfristige und
langfristig wieder probleme mit der
gegenwärtigen israelischen regierung
wurde der israelischen gesellschaft und
das ist die tatsache dass man glaubt
dass dieses datum
unsere langfristige interessen dass es
zu sagen ein jüdisch demokratisch und
gesicherte stadt zu sein
da stellt sich die frage ob die
maßnahmen die entscheidung denn die
diese regierung und unsere großen teil
der wirtschaft richten
hilfe bei der realisierung der ziele die
wir uns als stark und gesellschaft
gestellt haben und ich meine richtig
sagt die tatsache dass die israelisch
verneinen dass es noch ein problem gibt
der auf eine lösung warte und das ist ja
nicht so wenn man mit diesem problem
nicht so recht kommt dass das wird sich
einiges von sich selber lösen
das wird nicht der fall sein und deshalb
glaube ich auch wenn wir heute
realistische einsehen müssen dass die
endgültige beilegung des konfliktes
nicht in absehbarer zeit ist und wenn
die annahme ist dass hier auch der
palästinensische seite kann partner
abend nicht dem wir heute darüber
sprechen können
dann muss israel einseitige schritte in
ihrem nationalen interessen nehmen wir
unsere sicherheit nicht gefährden aber
ein schritt auf die in die scheidung
zwischen uns und den palästinensern
aufnehmen das ist eine große frage eine
haben die nicht gefragt und der richtige
fehler welche die auch damit
zusammenhängen dass ist seit zwei jahren
in einem innenstadt politische und
stabile verhältnisse lebt dass wir schon
bereit der wahl hinter uns haben und ich
setzte scheint auch nicht ausgeschlossen
zu sein und das sorgt nicht dafür dass
entscheidungen getroffen werden können
in eine rötliche haut und weise und so
meine ich mit hippies auf
sind dass manche frieda getankt wurden
die ja dann diese stimmung aufgeheizt
haben und die dann anschließend auch
dazu geführt haben dass kam es durch
auch die tatsache dass innerhalb des
politischen lage momentan auch eine
blockade herrscht und eine krise
zwischen kamaz in gefahr doch das kann
man eigentlich nicht in anspruch
genommen zu haben der verteidigen
der verteidiger des tempelberges und so
hat er dann israelische und die marke
umgestellt
die lage in jerusalem die sonne so
werden dass ramadan aufgeheizt ist und
dazu trage nicht nur arabischer
jugendlicher weit dann auch extreme
israelische bei und bahre entscheidungen
die er von der israelischen seite
getroffen worden sind wie ja nicht
hilfreich waren um die lage zu
deeskalieren so ich kann noch mal kurz
in die kommentare weil ich möchte euch
wirklich einmal bitten sachlich zu
bleiben auch untereinander
denn wenn man mal kurz auf meinem
rechner schalten ich habe mir einen
kommentar ausgesucht von dreister der
sagt bleibt sachlich leute hast hat
diesen konflikt erst verursacht dem
schließen wir uns sehr gerne an und auch
alle anschuldigungen wir würden hier
nicht objektiv berichten oder wir würden
nur berichten wenn israel angegriffen
wird
das stimmt so nicht wir berichten immer
dann wenn etwas wichtiges in der region
passiert und dieser konflikt den wir
gerade erleben den wir auch gerade
teilweise live erleben
den hat es in den letzten jahren einfach
so nicht gegeben deswegen schauen wir
hin und wir schalten jetzt mal zu meinem
kollegen michael d führung in tel aviv
der die ersten informationen hat über
mögliche verletzte oder schäden was
kannst du uns sagen
jetzt gehen gerade wie die sirenen los
es gibt erste berichte über mindestens
einen ernsthaft verletzten man hört ja
auch sirenen von krankenwagen aber
detailliert kann ich hier keine auskunft
darüber geben weil ich da einfach kein
anblick habe wir bekommen so viele sms
von nachrichtenagenturen auf die handys
und was wir hier sehen können der
dunkelheit ist auch relativ wenig was
ist denn jetzt zu erwarten wie wird das
israelische militär reagieren jaro der
ministerpräsident hat ja schon
angekündigt ist wird was kommen aber
weiß man doch schon genaueres ich
fürchte das wird ein sehr massiver
gegenschlag werden erstmal aus der luft
aber der generalstab hat ja auch schon
nicht ausgeschlossen
das ist auch zur bodenoperationen kommt
das ist ein sehr heikles unterfangen es
gab ja schon 2014 einen bodenkrieg in
gaza der war auch für israel sehr
verlustreich aber wenn die lage so
weiter eskaliert wird die israelische
seite mit sicherheit nicht nachgeben und
weiter von auf ihre militärische stärke
setzen
michael an vielen dank für deine
eindrücke und für die
live-berichterstattung was da im
hintergrund fliegt sind dass ich hatte
gerade so ein paar lichter gesehen ich
hoffe dass es nicht gefährlich ist das
ist eine der iron dome abfangraketen
tatsächlich so sieht das dann bei euch
live aus ja okay und ich höre gerade von
meinem kollegen aus der region versuchen
jetzt doch noch mal nach ost jerusalem
zu schalten michael vielen dank erstmal
nach tel aviv
und tatsächlich scheint es so zu sein
dass die leitung steht nach ost
jerusalem wo meine kollegin die freie
journalistin alena der marine ist
deutsch-israelische palästinenserin
alina wo bist du denn gerade eigentlich
ich bin gerade im american ich hoffe ihr
könnt mich hören dass das schönste hotel
der welt damals die friedensprozesse
auch stattgefunden haben und ich habe
mich gerade hierhin geflüchtet weil ich
eigentlich ein scherz war die situation
dort angucken wollte aber dann sind
israelische polizisten gerade mit
pferden ob die leute losgegangen und
haben die menschen dort rausgeschmissen
auf der straße
soldaten waren dann bin ich hier um die
ecke ins american colony hotel gerade
gegangen und habe ihr kurz zuflucht
gesucht
das heißt die situation ist dort vor ort
wirklich angespannt und auch so dass du
sagst auf die straße kann ich gerade
nicht gehen du bist ja schon seit
längeren unterwegs in jerusalem wie hast
du den gestrigen tag erlebt also gerade
auch um die al-aksa-moschee herum
also es ist so ein bisschen immer es hat
immer zwei seiten würde ich sagen
einerseits sehr angespannt natürlich mit
all dem was gerade zusammen kommt
einerseits natürlich ganz zentrales
situation um scherben die familien aus
den häusern zwangs evakuiert werden
sollen um platz zu machen für siedler
das hat ja viel zu protesten gesorgt
eben bis heute und wird auch in den
nächsten tagen und auch weltweit
und dann natürlich gleichzeitig dieser
jerusalem tag mit dem marsch der durch
die altstadt stattfinden sollte es war
sehr sehr angespannt aber andererseits
muss ich sagen erlebt man es also ist
mein eindruck dann doch immer dass die
menschen das einfach so was von gewöhnt
sind gerade in ost jerusalem das auch
wenn mit gummigeschossen da er wie
geschossen wird und an situationen da
sind in den ich mich eigentlich direkt
irgendwo vergleiche und mich zurückziehe
einfach nur als jemand der das
beobachten will dass gleichzeitig die
stände weiter auf haben die leute weiter
brot und saft verkaufen die kinder
weiter spielen
ich glaube traurigerweise ist diese
diese präsenz von gewalt gerade einfach
so normal geworden für die leute dass
das es ja gar nicht mehr so sehr
schockiert wie es jetzt ja jemanden wie
mich der jetzt sein leben sagen
deutschland verbracht hat wie schaffst
du das denn jetzt ein
wie ist die lage dort von dem gebiet
produkt ist wird das heute abend noch
richtig eskalieren oder hast du eher das
gefühl dass auch die anwohner vor ort
ein interesse haben das jetzt erst mal
sacken zu lassen weil die letzten platte
hat auch sehr gewalt geraten waren und
das haben wir gerade gesehen es gab
raketenangriffe aus dem gazastreifen
richtung
aviv das noch die stimmung herrscht wir
wissen doch mal ganz zur ruhe kommen
ich glaube die menschen wünschen sich
ehrlicherweise sehr zur ruhe zu kommen
ich war eben gerade die ecke und bin da
in einfamilienhaus eingegangen um dieses
interview mit euch zu führen und die
wollen zur ruhe komme das problem sie
können nicht zur ruhe kommen weil in
ihrer straße eben die siedler sind die
waren auch da die dort ins einzelne
häuser schon eingezogen sind die auch
präsenz zeigen die keinen schritt gehen
ohne begleitet zu sein von israelischen
kräfte das heißt wie die menschen hier
gibt es ja gar keine normalität mehr
wenn man jetzt zb vom chef darf spricht
und eben gerade was tatsächlich so ich
wollte mir die situation vor ort
angucken und als ich dort ankam war ein
riesenfisch angebaut das ist ja gerade
ramadan fasten zeit der letzten tage ist
morgen und da waren ganz viele leute
finden das so vielleicht 200 leute vor
allem wirklich junge mädels und jungs
vielleicht um die anfang 20 die wirklich
deutschen tisch aufgebaut haben und
gegessen haben gemeinsam das fasten
gebrochen haben und dann sind halt
irgendwann die kräfte da einfach rein
und haben die leute und mich dass ich
mit
also ich glaube die menschen wirklich
ruhe aber die ruhe kommt ja auch nicht
zu ihnen also ich glaube dass die
grundprobleme müssen gelöst werden
denn auch wenn sie gar nichts tun ist
die lage ja nicht ruhig siehst du das
denn überhaupt dass die grundprobleme
gelöst werden ich habe ja gerade länger
mit shimon stein dem ehemaligen
israelischen botschafter in deutschland
geredet der eher pessimistisch klang der
sagte tatsächlich also wörtlich ich habe
das talent eindruck beide seiten sind
noch nicht reif für einen
friedensprozess und solange das so nicht
ist wird ist weiter angespannt bleiben
und es wird immer wieder zu konflikten
kommen
wie siehst du das was vielleicht wichtig
ist nochmals zu betonen
ich sehe gerade in ramallah und würde
deswegen natürlich viele
palästinensischen stimmen auch wenn aber
eigentlich israel
das heißt meine familie leben alle in
israel ich kenne viele stimmen
ich bin diesmal schwierig von beiden
seiten zu sprechen denn es gibt nicht
wirklich zwei seiten also wenn man es
der aktuelle umfragen anguckt fühlt sich
die mehrheit der palästinenser von ihrer
regierung überhaupt nicht vertreten
die letzten wahlen vor 15 jahren
stattgefunden
das heißt von zwei seiten zu sprechen
wenn die palästinensische seite dann die
behörde wäre ihr glaube ich auch
schwierig weil westliche seiten würdest
du das sehen
ich glaube dass die meisten menschen die
meisten palästinenser die ich kenne sich
ein ende der besatzung in erster linie
wünschen ein ende der siedlungen ein
ende der checkpoints bewegungsfreiheit
quasi dass das würden sie brauchen um in
der usk gespräche jetzt nur von der
us-bank das ist ja noch mal eine andere
situation als in gaza mit hamas da kann
ich jetzt nicht zu sagen weil ich jetzt
israelische staatsbürgerinnen dahin darf
aber in der westbank oder im
westjordanland wünschen sich die
menschen in aller erster linie ein ende
der besatzung
denn so lange dass die besatzung nicht
zu ende ist gibt es keine ruhe für die
menschen nicht erlebt dass er heute ich
bin aus ramallah
du musst durch die checkpoints also
lasst einfach im alltag durch die
besatzung so viele so viele dinge die
seine grundrechte einschränken das
natürlich also auf der basis wird alles
china und israel niemals zu einer
friedlichen situation kommen dass sind
die grund grundprobleme und wenn man
sich die aktuelle situation anguckt
sieht es eben nicht danach aus als ob
die besatzung bald ein ende haben wird
und insofern kann man dich wahnsinnig
hoffnungsvoll in die zukunft leider
blicken dann hoffe ich dass du sicher
bleibt in jerusalem heute abend das ist
nicht zu weiteren schweren
auseinandersetzungen kommt pass auf dich
auf genau die bitte auch an unseren
kollegen michael beverungen der in tel
aviv für uns aus ich mache den live
stream an dieser stelle für heute zu ich
danke dir für deine eindrücke
unterländer schilderungen und hoffe dass
du uns auch social media weiter
berichten wir es wie es aussieht ich
danke euch für eure kommentare zumindest
für die sachlichen ich hoffe wir konnten
euch gute informieren und euch so sagte
ich wie möglich informieren das ist ein
schwierig
das thema wo es mehrere wahrheiten gibt
das haben wir gerade auch schon gehört
von shimon stein jeder hat seine
erzählung und am ende müssen sich alle
darauf einigen was denn jetzt eigentlich
die beste version ist und wie es
vielleicht doch noch irgendwann zu einem
gemeinsamen frieden kommen kann das
zieht gerade aber nicht so aussieht
werden die beilage weiter für euch im
blick halten und sind bald wieder für
euch da machts gut bis dahin einen
schönen abend noch
und tschüss